marco's laugh was low and warm and
rolling
he started unwrapping his hands it would
have been so easy to hurt him while he
did it that she was fairly certain he
had a hidden way to defend himself and
if not
the impression that he might was defense
enough she wasn't here to kill him
she was here to push him into saying
something locking her in a cage would
have been a tacit admission she was a
threat he wanted her to see that she was
powerless
to make the prison walls herself there
had been a time
it would have worked she was betting
that he didn't realize that time had
passed and she was betting that it had
passed when he narrowed his eyes at her
shaking his head she still felt a tug of
humiliation in her throat
familiar as an old habit so perhaps the
truth was more complicated
hey guys pete here a bit of time has
passed since we watched episode six
of season five of the expanse so now
it's time to discuss and preview episode
seven
if you're not familiar with my weekly
release schedule this is a continuation
of the breakdown i did
right after episode 6 aired we're going
to look at where
all the character stories left off some
of the details that we might have missed
on the first
watch and put that all together for
speculation on where things are headed
in episode seven
this will contain spoilers for
everything that happened through episode
six
but since amazon hasn't been doing
trailers or
promos for season five if you're caught
up then there won't be anything you
haven't seen here
as someone who's read all the books i
will be referring to them but i won't be
giving away future spoilers there either
with all that out of the way let's get
into it for abasaral as part of the
story we did get a new acting secretary
general
and as i mentioned in my episode
breakdown he is out of his depth but
he's smart enough to know that which is
a good sign
and he's looking to avasarala for
guidance in the midst of this emergency
an interesting detail while they're
talking is that we can see
some of the statistics on the screen
behind him when he comes in the room
on that we can see that the feed is
titled unn luna
incident report and it's encrypted and
then we can see some of the numbers if
we zoom in
we see that it says sea walls breached
42
flooding 45 casualties nine percent
there's a marker of where the hai sung
tower used to be
and it says homelessness 29 considering
how
little time has passed since the rocks
dropped i'm guessing the real details of
how bad things are on earth is going to
come at the end of the season
maybe the second to last episode or the
last episode i'm guessing we'll get bits
and pieces along the way but it does
seem like they're putting that off as a
reveal
and this tweet from the writer's account
says that those inconsistencies that
we've seen
are deliberate so i guess if we look at
the other stories
and the amount of time that it's going
to take amos and peaches to get to
baltimore
it's kind of like it's going to take the
u.n that same amount of time to get a
handle on exactly how bad these impacts
are going to be
for the planet as a whole alongside of
that we know that avasarala
is also going to be dealing with her
personal issue which is that she can't
get a hold of her husband
and it's starting to feel like he might
not be okay another interesting detail
in this scene
i mentioned it in the comments a lot of
people pointed out that the names in her
contact list were
characters from tv shows then i saw this
post from shaky 51
on the expanse subreddit and he pointed
out that all of these are characters
from tv shows who had multiple actors
play them
darren stevens from bewitched the
mountain from game of thrones
becky connor from roseanne and so on
it's funny because obviously arjun had
been played by two actors as well
over the series so that's all we really
know about things with the un
is back in a position where she has a
chance to do something about what's
happening
and we'll wait to find out how bad
things really are
another place where we're gonna see some
of that damage is with amos and peaches
they've got a long way to travel and
they need to stay off the radar because
of the authorities
obviously clarissa is a convict without
a prison
but amos is also operating under a false
identity eric warned him that he wasn't
sure the identification of amos burton
that he transferred to timmy
would hold up under scrutiny if you
listen closely when they approached the
relief station you could hear an
announcement
saying that if you don't have an id you
have to submit to dna testing
so in the last episode we saw that amos
and pizzas are on their own
and they're heading towards baltimore he
mentioned that he knew people there
the kind you want to be around in times
like this that sounds like eric and his
crew
but we can't forget that he told amos
that he'd kill him if he ever came back
to his
town there's still a lot of distance in
between them and baltimore
and they did pick up supplies and a pair
of bikes at the prepper's compound
i would guess that not much will happen
in the days it takes them to get there
we might check in to see what the damage
looks like but it seems likely that the
action in their story won't pick up
until they get there
these two coming together and their
traveling is all about character
development and i think we saw most of
that in the last episode so their story
might take a backseat for a little while
we saw with holden he is taking the
rossi and they're going after the zamaya
he has his temporary crew that's led by
bull and monica has joined them
after thinking about this some i kind of
like the idea that monica is along for
the ride
she's not one of my favorite characters
overall in the series but holden is cut
off from communicating with
naomi and amos and with fred being out
of the picture
monica and her contacts might be useful
they could help to inform holden
about what's going on in the belt she
was able to get her hands on a video
feed of cordazar being kidnapped and she
may turn out to be really useful in this
storyline
after all she did get the flight path of
the zamaya and so now they will be
trying to chase down the stolen
proto-molecule sample
moving on to alex and bobby they were
able to get out of their last scrape
with the free navy
and they are back up and running but the
razorback isn't a gunship so they can't
really do much
other than flee the free navy it's not
like they can engage with them
also enough time has probably passed at
this point that they have no chance of
catching back up with the bar keith
soviter and babbage are probably gone
for all intents and purposes
they seem to make their pass off to the
free navy with those ships
we heard drummer's crew say that it was
a light
cruiser which is the pella and two heavy
frigates which is what they were
traveling with
as their escorts those are the ships
that they dropped off it seems like that
part of their mission is now complete as
marco has those ships
unlike the other members of the rossi
crew alex is able to contact holden as
far as we could tell so it's possible
that they might enter into that hunt for
the zamaya beyond that we're just not
sure at this point
so i'd be interested to hear what you
guys think these two are going to get
into
in the comments one of the biggest
developments in
episode 6 was drummer and her family
making the tough decision to join up
with the free navy
drummer sees the writing on the wall as
she's on the pella
and she's getting ready to meet with
marco she says that he's consolidating
support amongst the factions of the belt
and oxana says
if he has black sky and golden bow with
him then half the opa will rally to his
banner i think the conversation she had
with marco did a great job of setting up
a very tenuous
partnership that we have to imagine
might fail down the road we know she has
no respect for marco on a personal level
because of the deaths of ashford and
fred she made this
plane her crewmates know this and from
the conversation we could see that marco
knows this as well
at the same time her and her family
believe that joining
sides with him and these other factions
of the opa
is the best way for them to ensure their
own survival
they've traded crewmates with marcos
sending karol
onto drummer's ship and i think at the
very least this is an indication that he
knows he can't
exactly trust drummer so he wants one of
his best people to be there to watch her
there could be more to that but we'll
have to wait and see
as far as what comes next with drummer
and her part of the story when she saw
phillip she figured out that naomi was
on the ship based off of what he said
that may play a part in how she feels
about this arrangement but it doesn't
really change the reality of the
situation they can't get into a fight
with marco
he way outpowers everyone in the belt so
it's very possible
that we won't see all that much more
happen with this in this
season you know there was a big
conversation online going on about how
people thought that the last episode was
a filler episode
i would disagree with that on the basis
of the definition of a filler episode
and then also disagree with anybody who
said nothing happened in that episode
but all of that aside the reality of
these two books book five and six is
that they are a duology
book five introduces the free navy the
dynamics in the system
change we see what the stakes are the
characters move around
and they grow and it all works to make
it matter
when we get to the conclusion of this
part of the series
it's definitely going somewhere you can
trust me on that but i'm not sure that
we'll get resolutions to all the
different story lines
before the end of season six one place
where i do expect some movement
soon if not the next episode then in the
next two episodes at the very least
is with naomi's story and her being a
captive on the pella
just like episode six was heavy on the
amos story
i think we have one of those coming up
for naomi really soon
in the last episode we saw that philip
was kind of warming up to her
and we can imagine that's something that
marco won't be happy about
and that'll be on top of the fact that
sin has already kind of stuck his neck
out for her
and got in marco's face in front of the
entire crew
i mentioned in my breakdown that i was a
little unsure of the way they're
depicting marco
and then i had a lot of people asking
for details in the comments
what it boils down to is that we're
missing naomi telling us
who marco is in her eyes and i open with
an excerpt from one of her chapters so
you can get an idea of how that works
what the characters doing on the show
might be a hundred percent in line with
what he did in the books but it feels
different to me without that framing and
i trust the writers
they've earned that i'm just saying that
as a fan who has
expectations tv show marco has made some
decisions that don't make sense to me at
this point and i say that all knowing
very well that
it all might make sense in a couple of
episodes another thing that some people
mention in the comments is that
marco is actually doing a lot of stuff
but we don't actually see what any of it
is
at the end of the episode we see him
watching naomi and philip together and
then we see him pull up this display of
his fleet where he's thinking about
using the chet's mocha which she arrived
on to intercept the rasanante on his way
to the zamaya
so most of what we see marco doing is
talking to the other characters but
there's a whole lot of other stuff going
on that hasn't yet been revealed
based on him looking at the rossi
chasing after the zamaya
i think we could say that he is going to
be planning on doing something with that
in the next episode
and obviously naomi will be trying to do
her best to
undermine anything he's doing and trying
to get herself out of this situation
and back to her crew on the rossi the
name of the episode
is the belter word for goodbye and i saw
the idea out there that we might see
this flashback scene from the trailer
where phillips a child in the happy
times of marco and naomi's relationship
considering that she had to say goodbye
to that family because of the way that
things were there's definitely a
possibility of that
and there's also the possibility that
she has to say goodbye again
so that's something to think about so i
think that covers where everybody's at
and that seems like a good place to
leave it let me know in the comments
what you think's gonna happen
your theories your predictions what
you're hoping to see
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon